every bad guy in the world could be
gunning for the bruners at the end of
Fubar season one from Twisted love
triangles to shattered Secret Lives
let's break down how they got there and
where they go next Arnold Schwarzenegger
is back in his element to Netflix's
action comedy Fubar he Stars the CIA
agent Luke Bruner who is near in
retirement that's when he discovers his
daughter Emma has also been keeping the
same secret from the family and working
as an operative after discovering Emma's
secret Luke works together with her in a
team consisting of Alden Rue Barry and
Tina their main mission is to take down
an international terrorist and arms
dealer Boro the group gets close a few
times but the season sees him often
having to shake up their approach turns
out their man is a bit of a slippery
customer who has his own network of bad
guys doing his bidding the other story
of Fubar is how Luke and Emma's personal
lives continue to suffer due to their
top secret work Luke tries to encourage
his daughter to learn from his mistakes
and not repeat them but this only
accelerates her issues take your
daughter to work day is going well she
and her Beyonce Carter break up after
she starts Snogging her colleague Alden
whom she has inflicted feelings for
similarly Luke has his relationship was
as he rekindles the romance with his
ex-wife tally whom he has never gotten
over there's a problem there though
tally is in a relationship with Dani but
she promises she will break it off for
Luke after Luke breaks her heart for the
second time and what he deems an effort
to spare her from further pain tally
takes a plunge and decides she wants to
commit and marry Donnie pubar's season 1
ends on an action-packed note that ties
up a few loose threads but also
introduces a bunch of new ones into the
mix Luke makes a big call in the season
finale after Emma and Boro work together
to try and avoid the impending explosion
in sardovia while Luke has the ability
to help Boro out of danger he decides
against it fearing that he will come
after his family later on you gave me
your word let me out sorry I can't let
you come after her despite his closeness
to the criminal as a child and his
previous reluctance Luke leaves the
villain to perish in the nuclear
explosion and escapes with his daughter
back home Luke announces His official
retirement from the CIA and gets
blindsided by the news that tally is
marrying Donnie initially he accepts the
decision and wishes both tally and Tani
well despite having no plans to attend
the wedding Emma eggs her father on
though telling him to fight for her
mother and what he wants I'm trying to
be the bigger man you're being the
Dumber Man spurned by his daughter's
encouragement Luke arrives at the church
before the ceremony and tells tally the
truth the whole truth and nothing but it
reveals everything about his past as a
CIA agent explaining how it was the
reason for his odd behavior all those
years ago and how he kept it a secret to
protect his family and all of a sudden
Luke's car explodes out outside of the
church it goes from church bells to
Hell's Bells as terrorists swarm the
ceremony and start firing Luke and Emma
pull out their weapons and return the
gunfire revealing themselves as
something much more to the wedding
guests a burnt looking borrow reappears
holding tally at gunpoint and demanding
revenge in a typical dastardly
villainous monologue he discusses how he
survived the explosion and found Emma
and Luke his nefarious plan is for them
to shoot each other in front of their
loved ones the two of you the two Liars
base each other
take your guns and point them at each
other's heads tally uses the metal that
Luke showed her as proof of his past the
stab and unstabilized borrow who then
takes a hail of bullets from Emma and
Luke however both father and daughter
understand this is only the start of
their problems since their true
identities have been compromised and
they believe Boro might have sold the
information to others a black van
arrives in Luke Emma Italy Donnie Carter
Barry Alden Rue and the rest of the
family including Oscar Bruner and his
family jump in it's made clear that
everyone's life is about to change and
they can no longer go back to how it was
before Luke even describes the situation
as being particularly fubarbed up beyond
all repair fubar's season 1 is all about
secrets and the Damage they cause in the
long run it's also abundantly obvious
that the lack of honesty is behind Luke
and Tally's marriage falling apart in
the first place she believes he sells
gym equipment for a living and is a
generally unreliable human being who
lets her down Luke did have the chance
to come clean to her though when they
reignited the relationship in the season
his plan for retirement was already in
place so he could have been honest much
earlier but he lied again you deserve to
know the truth
yerry has a gambling problem he puts her
through the ringer yet again by luring
her in and dumping her when it becomes
serious then once he realizes he may
lose her forever to Donnie he unloads
everything on her wedding day while it
might sound like a grand Jester to win
her back it isn't it shows a bit of
Luke's selfishness and trust issues he
might hide behind the fact that he's
protecting her and the family from
potential danger by not disclosing what
he really does but being a part of their
lives and in that line of work will
always put them at risk as the finale
proves the least it could have reported
her was the truth from the start he only
told her now because she was about to
get married to someone else and he
didn't like it
the show features a lot of guns and
fists flying but at its heart is well
matters of the heart the season finale
leaves a question mark on the status of
two major love triangles and no matter
the outcome some beloved characters will
be left broken-hearted here the first
involves Luke tally and Donnie anyone
can see that Luke and tally share a deep
connection and it has never gone away
despite their divorce plus they realize
the Sparks still exists after their
latest playing and there's Dany a nice
guy who has genuine feelings for tally
he might not have the Bluster of Luke
but he treats tally well and is there
for her when she needs him I mean he's
trying to replace me his car coded the
entire family please stop saying that
with all three together now it remains
to be seen if Luke will make a play for
tally in front of Donnie or tally will
admit her feelings for Luke in all
likelihood it looks like Dani will be
the biggest loser in this situation then
there's the drama between Emma Alden and
Carter much like Donnie Carter is the
secure reliable option for Emma however
Alden possesses a more dangerous and
seductive appeal she has already cheated
on Carter with Alden and it's evident
there are also feelings there while
Carter and Emma may be broken up there's
a hint they may try to work things out
again however Alden might have something
to say about that after the gunfire in
the church no one has much time to
process what just happened it's
understandable the adrenaline must be
through the roof and they are more
concerned about their safety than
anything else at the moment however once
the dust settles the Noggins will start
ticking and questions will be asked
imagine how someone like Oscar must feel
knowing his father and sister are CIA
agents and he never knew about it surely
you must feel a sense of betrayal at how
they kept this from him for so long so
you're all CIA
and Emma similarly spare a thought for
Port Carter he already believes the
relationship between him and Emma
consisted of Lies now this extra bit of
additional info will make him question
everything about their relationship
including if it was even real in the
first place make no mistake about it
Luke and Emma have a lot of explaining
to do to their friends and family here
and won't be able to brush this incident
under the carpet Tina doesn't make it to
the church as Barry's date since she's
wrapping something up at the office she
receives a call and suddenly she
switches from English to Russian
it's a shocking moment that leaves the
audience with a lot of questions about
Tina and her real motivations at the
start of Fubar season 1 Tina arrives on
the scene as a transfer from another
department she starts a romance with
Barry and quickly earns the trust of the
rest of the team later she reveals to
Barry that she is meant to be
transferred out again undeterred he
pulls internal strings and calls on a
few favors to ensure she stays where she
is so they can continue their
relationship however the big reveal in
the season finale indicates that Tina
may not be who she claims to be there's
a possibility that she could be a double
agent and working with adversaries to
infiltrate the CIA including fake in a
relationship with Barry to gain his
trust equally concerning is the identity
of the person on the opposite end of her
phone call is it her real boss or
potentially the villain for another
season of the show
despite looking atmospheres none of
their loved ones are actually hurt in
Fubar season 1. they escape boreal's
wrath relatively unscathed which means
they are incredibly lucky and fortunate
however neither of those elements makes
for riveting television shows so this is
merely the Calm before the storm saving
all the main characters here it's a sure
sign that there's major trouble Brewing
down the road for the protagonists in
essence Luke and Emma haven't suffered
at all Oro wanted revenge against him
for what they did to ham in for messing
up his plans but he didn't succeed in
the slightest the worst thing he did is
reveal their secret to their family and
friends that being said there is
potential Danger on the horizon
especially considering the group of
untrained and unarmed people with them
now while no one doubts Luke Emma and
the rest of the cia's crew's ability to
defend themselves they're surrounded by
regular foe who make the best targets
for Rogues oh man I picked the wrong day
to get high unless Fubar takes a drastic
left turn it's likely the audience has
seen the last to borrow there's no
chance he survived all those bullets to
the chest and Rue makes sure he's done
by popping him one more time for good
measure so that's the curtain call and
his time is the villain of the show as
Luke States though it's uncertain how
many others know Luke and Emma's real
identities now oral could have sold the
information to the highest bidder or
even offered it up voluntarily as a
middle finger to the pruners perhaps you
might have told a few of the other
Insidious characters he interacted with
earlier in the season alternatively
there's the real possibility that Tina
and the Mysterious person she spoke to
on the phone could be revealed as the
next antagonists here she's been a
double agent all along this could be the
next phase of some master plan when we
may learn more about the potential Fubar
season 2.
foreign
[Music]